[Music]
so so listen listen stop copying me stop
copying stop copying me I am Vengeance I
why
I'm Vengeance all right Vengeance you're
[__] fired what no I'm your
replacement no you're not I'm going to
have to site the case a ain't broke V
don't fix seriously I don't even know
why you're here what's the difference
I'm the Batman you're Batman okay I
don't mean to be Sean Parker here but
you can drop the the nobody wants to go
to the Facebook and nobody's afraid of
the Batman I don't want to trigger you
but uh
you're the dinosaur look at that suit so
2005 okay what's so great about your
suit how how is this an improvement over
this are you kidding me use your
eyeballs Cal goes
up the cowl goes up okay yeah no I I was
just praying I hadn't heard you but I
did so you're you have a a turtleneck so
the chilly rain doesn't land on the back
of your head I know you're goofing
around right now but
yeah when it's raining pretty hard the
cow up version is better than the cow
down version okay keeps my neck warm cuz
this is the rainy season man Gotham is
wet sorry but what's up with that voice
what this voice yeah this voice rules
that voice sucks it rules it sucks yours
droes yours is too grally yours isn't
even masked it's just your regular Bruce
Wayne boys lowered yeah I want people to
lean in so I can pop them right in the
mouth you sound like you're getting
winded pulling the foil off of a single
serving yogurt well I actually am
plant-based so I don't eat yogurt so
yeah a lot of berries nuts and actually
Alfred makes a little mild avocado dip
for me every morning are you even
wearing black eye makeup are you just
low
iron you need to eat some [__] meat
you're going to need those calories when
you fight hardened criminals a there are
multiple ways to get broken 14 you don't
need to slaughter and take the life of
an animal to get it B I don't do much
fighting what I don't do much fighting I
get to the crime scene after it's
happened so going to poke my nose around
take some notes talk to the cops wait
you just walk around like a regular cop
yeah they like having me around Jesus
[__] look man you got to face it I'm
cool I'm Edy okay I'm Kirk Cobain yeah
cuz you're dead to me I think I made my
point I'm the winner you're the
winner I'm about to make my
point August
6th sometimes life hurts but then the
wounds scar over and you're then mainly
just scarves Sor are you journaling at
me scars are like muscles on the outside
of your body and they make you strong
against dicks who don't understand how
cool you are my scars make me so
strong they make me stronger
than metal the metal
wind we deserve better than this you
know what I I'll finish this later
fine you okay buddy sometimes that kind
of stuff takes a lot out of me drops my
blood sugar levels yeah I forgot to
bring a snack do you have any food okay
so vengeance is asking me if I have any
food yeah you're don't have anything
here I I do have some crackers rice or
wheat it's wheat I'm gluten-free [__]
okay oh no whoa are you okay
Bruce
I'm cool man I'm
cool I'm
cool but gluten you can't handle nobody
touch me nobody touch
me
hey you do this what is that
adrenaline trade from a bu come
yeah no I don't I don't inject myself
with bul dick every night before I go
out I'm in the bad car just cranking
shot after shot you got to go man this
feels like an NA situation you need help
the type of help that a popped up caller
can't give
[Music]
you